et
j'en viens à Monsieur le Ministre
à vous poser une question vous êtes
comme moi comme d'autres dans cette
hémicycle ce qu'on appelle un tranche un
transfuge de un transfuge de classe vous
avez eu une trajectoire tout à fait
particulière et pourtant vous avez des
origines modestes vous avez été comme
moi je crois boursier qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé monsieur le ministre à quel
moment avez-vous oublié d'où vous venez
comment Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
brutaliser ce que vous avez connu et qui
vous regarde monsieur le ministre que
vous est-il arrivé réveillez-vous
réveillez-vous monsieur le ministre et
souvenez-vous de celui que vous avez été
[Musique]